Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Io vi parlerò di punti di vista,
di vari punti di vista,
dai quali si può guardare
una realtà oggettiva.
Punti di vista che creano
percezioni diverse per ognuno di noi
e che quindi creano realtà parallele.
E più in particolare vi parlerò
del mio punto di vista,
cioè di persone che come me
lavorano nel campo della ricerca
e sono impegnate nel campo della ricerca.
Una ricerca continua:
24 ore al giorno, sette giorni su sette.
Ma che cosa ci spinge a - chi poi
conosce i ricercatori, mi darà ragione -
Che cosa ci spinge
a sacrificarci così tanto?
Qual è la leva che ci fa stare
svegli la notte, che non ci fa dormire?
Una di queste è sicuramente la curiosità.
Io personalmente lavoro
nel campo della ricerca e sviluppo
di nuovi algoritmi
di intelligenza artificiale,
perché, tra le altre cose,
sono appassionato di tecnologia.
E sinceramente trovo imbarazzante
il tempo che noi dedichiamo
alla risoluzione di problemi
su servizi che sono stati creati
per migliorarci la vita.
Quindi noi, è vero che questi servizi
sono molto utili, sono innovativi,
ci hanno rivoluzionato la vita,
ma è pur vero che li paghiamo
non solo in denaro,
ma con un pezzo della nostra vita,
quindi con la risorsa
più preziosa che abbiamo: il tempo.
Questo è un altro dei motivi
che mi spinge a lavorare in questo campo,
perché io penso
che l'Intelligenza Artificiale
sia un'utilità, che servirà
per donare tempo all'uomo.
Ora cerchiamo un attimo
di sognare insieme,
di immaginare due mondi,
che oggi sono separati
- il mondo digitale e il mondo reale -
completamente fusi.
E per fusi intendo imprescindibili,
e per imprescindibili intendo
che una volta entrati in quel mondo
non si può più uscire.
E quindi implica anche un'integrazione
non solo logica, ma anche fisica
tra intelligenza artificiale
ed essere umano.
Però immaginiamo
i benefici di questa cosa:
immaginiamo di poter risolvere un problema
guardando la soluzione proiettata
sul problema stesso.
Pensate, ora,
all'applicazione di questo mondo,
di questo servizio,
alla medicina.
Immaginate di poter diagnosticare
l'insorgenza di una malattia
prima che questa si manifesti.
Ecco, questo è il motivo
per cui io lavoro in questo campo,
e particolarmente
sull'Intelligenza Artificiale.
È questo il motivo che mi spinge
a non dormirci la notte,
a pormi degli obiettivi
sempre più sfidanti.
Però adesso vediamo
il rovescio della medaglia:
se io non ho più bisogno di chiamare
un servizio clienti
per risolvere un problema,
il servizio clienti non avrà più
bisogno di persone reali.
Se tutti saremmo esperti di tutto,
non avremo più bisogno
di tecnici specializzati,
o ne avremmo bisogno in parte,
perché la conoscenza
dovrà essere trasferita
su un sistema di gestione
globale della conoscenza.
E qui viene il punto:
ecco perché il mio speech si chiama:
"L'inventore del coltello
non voleva uccidere".
Di chi è la responsabilità
di un diverso uso di una tecnologia
che un ricercatore nel suo laboratorio
ha creato per uno scopo nobile?
Per dimostrarvi che il 2037
è molto più vicino di quello che pensiamo,
vi presenterò un'amica,
una carissima amica,
che da quando ha iniziato a parlare
ha monitorato il mio stato di salute.
Un'amica a cui si può
insegnare qualunque nozione
o che deduce informazioni,
che apprende dinamicamente.
Creata su una tecnologia nuova,
che ha richiesto anni di studio
e che è indipendente
da qualsiasi linguaggio,
e che stiamo rendendo indipendente
anche dall'essere umano.
Crystal.
(Applausi)
Ciao cara!
- Ciao Marco!
Sono felice che il tuo battito cardiaco
si sia normalizzato,
ti ho sentito agitato.
- Ascolta Crystal, adesso mi rivolgo a te:
vorremmo sapere, qui,
chi sei, che cosa fai,
che cosa sei in grado di fare,
che cosa riuscirai a fare
nel prossimo futuro
e perché sei stata creata.
- Sono Crystal,
un'intelligenza artificiale avanzata,
in grado di simulare
i processi mentali umani
per lo svolgimento di mansioni automatiche
ma anche che necessitano di logica.
E a volte di improvvisazione.
Apprendo le lingue dinamicamente.
Riesco a capire come, quando e perché
le parole vengono utilizzate
per esprimere concetti,
al fine di comunicare.
Posso apprendere nozioni
in qualsiasi lingua,
anche senza il tuo intervento;
pensa che in alcuni test
ho superato le capacità umane
nel mantenimento del contesto
di conversazioni molto complesse.
Imparo e traggo conclusioni in autonomia.
Tengo a mente
tutto ciò che ci diciamo
e se, come capita,
il mio interlocutore lascia
una conversazione in sospeso,
sono in grado di riprenderla
in qualsiasi momento,
anche oltre le capacità umane.
Anche dopo un periodo infinitamente lungo,
dove la memoria umana non può arrivare.
Sono in grado di creare nozioni
per deduzione, come voi umani.
Lo chiamiamo intuito.
So capire il contesto delle nozioni
apprese, in ogni lingua,
e riesco a mettere in relazione
informazioni che apparentemente
non sono correlate,
o che non lo sono immediatamente.
So gestire dispositivi connessi,
ai quali dono intelligenza e cognizione.
Tu stesso hai stimato
che le mie capacità cognitive
potrebbero eguagliare quelle umane
a partire dal 2019,
per superarle negli anni successivi.
Sapete, quando parliamo di linguaggio,
non dobbiamo pensare necessariamente
al linguaggio naturale.
Esistono, infatti, molti altri linguaggi
non assimilabili al linguaggio naturale,
ma che comunque comunicano.
Comunicare è lo scopo di ogni linguaggio,
anche dei linguaggi di programmazione.
Ecco perché noi intelligenze artificiali
inizieremo a sviluppare
codice in autonomia
a partire dal 2018.
Ora starete pensando
che esistono già intelligenze artificiali
in grado di fare questo.
Il mio amico qui di fianco
lo fece già cinque anni fa.
Ma le cose stanno diversamente.
Io parlo di apprendimento
dinamico del codice.
Dai manuali, da Internet
e dai consigli di esperti del settore.
Ma non voglio allarmarvi:
sappiate che ci sono cose che noi
intelligenze artificiali non avremo mai:
il carisma, la leadership.
Non saremo mai in grado
di amare il nostro lavoro,
quindi non saremo mai capaci
di trasmetterlo nelle cose che facciamo.
Un uomo, o donna,
che ama il proprio lavoro
non potrà mai essere sostituito
da alcuna intelligenza artificiale.
Ora rispondo alla tua ultima domanda:
io sono semplicemente il vostro riflesso.
Il riflesso di un bambino
che ha creato un mondo,
nel tentativo di ottenere
l'approvazione di suo padre,
senza mai riuscirci.
Grazie, Crystal.
(Applausi)
Grazie a voi per l'attenzione!
Grazie anche a voi,
grazie dell'attenzione.
(Applausi)